past
the US government has been running on
financial fumes for five months it would
have finally run out of money to pay the
bills on June 5th but the first step in
stopping any debt default has passed the
house after a contentious vote
I wanted to make history
I wanted to do something no other
Congress has done for the first time
in quite some time we'd spend less than
we spent the year before McCarthy
negotiated a deal with U.S President Joe
Biden to avert a financial crisis
but summon his own party were angered
there weren't deeper cuts to government
spending and stronger efforts to cut the
deficit that anger brought a novel from
them and it was directed at the leader
of their party in the house I'm trying
to figure out exactly
what
conservatives should be happy about some
Democrats were upset too at the cuts
that had been agreed but there was still
enough of them to push through the bill
from the very beginning house Democrats
were clear that we would not allow
extreme Mega Republicans to default on
our debt crash the economy or trigger a
job killing recession
a U.S debt default would create economic
Tremors which could spark a recession at
home and real issues globally one expert
says when the deal is agreed the
continuing problem of America's debt
won't go away and the big drivers of
debt were taken off the table at the
beginning what we call Social Security
uh aid for the elderly Medicare health
care for the elderly Medicaid Health
Care for the poor none of those were
touched and if those are the drivers of
federal debt the problem continues this
was the highest hurdle that the bill to
suspend the debt limit was likely to
face getting through the
republican-controlled house now that
it's done that it will go to the Senate
and then to the president's desk for
signing probably on Friday now both
sides will claim victory for this but
the biggest Fallout is likely to be for
Kevin McCarthy and he'll face calls from
inside his own party to be replaced this
speaker but that is another Capitol Hill
drama for another day Alan fish Al
Jazeera Washington